When you think of Nazi Germany and most likely think about the human rights
abuses and the concentration camps like Auschwitz,
but have you ever wondered what happened to the black people who lived under the
Third Reich?
It turns out that even though there were racial laws demanding the extermination
of the Jewish and the Roma people,
there were so few Africans living in Germany that they were not really
considered to be on of Hitler's main priorities.
One very special mixed race boy,
he grew up in Germany during the Third Reich.
Kinsey lived to tell the tale.
Not only did he manage to survive unscathed,
but he also desperately wanted to join the Nazi party.
He was an actual print since he grew up to become a writer.
This is the incredible story of Hums.
Massapequa.
Yeah.
Han's Juergen Massaquoi was born in Hamburg,
Germany in 1926 but he didn't look like most of the blond haired and blue eyed
baby is born into the country.
His mother,
birth of Bates was a German nurse and his father are harsh.
Massaquoi was the prince of the African country of Liberia.
One harms was born.
I'll hodge was a law student studying at Trinity College in Dublin.
The plan was for birth or indoor hodge to get married after graduation and she
lived with her future father in law came Mama Lu.
The king received his college education in the United States and became the
first ethnically African diplomat to live and work in Germany.
Liberia has elected a president,
so while the position of king was still a powerful one,
he was more of a figurehead for the tribal leadership.
For years,
King Mama Lu had lived with five wives,
which was a tribal tradition,
but he gave up that lifestyle in favor of a more western way of life and married
a woman named a Rachel Johnson.
They had several children together and they accepted birther on hands into their
happy home,
but at that time,
the only other mixed race children living in Germany will called the Rhineland
busters.
In 1919 western Germany was occupied by the allies,
which included African French soldiers.
The German women fought that these men were exciting and exotic and as many of
them had affairs with the African soldiers.
However,
after the soldiers left Germany,
many of the women were left pregnant since they gave birth to mixed race babies.
People were shocked since racist Germans were disgusted that women would ever do
this.
Many of these mothers could not handle raising the children alone and they were
called whores for having these affairs.
Children were given up for adoption and it's the government's spread propaganda
depicting black men is rapists.
These children were seen as the product of foreign brutality.
However,
only one woman out of the hundreds of mothers to mixed race children ever came
forward to claim that she had been raped by a black soldier.
While the rest said that that had a consensual romantic relationship and the
1920s Germany's economy,
it was struggling to recover from World War One.
The mass of family were royalty and they were wealthy and exotic.
This made them well-respected in the city of Hamburg and they were treated by
everyone as esteemed guests.
Bertha bees has got to experience living with this royal treatment and she was
prepared to move to Liberia,
to get married and have a new life.
As an African princess,
unfortunately are harsh.
Abandons Beth around Houghtons and he never returned to Germany.
King Mama Lu was furious with his son and he threatened to force our harsh to
marry birther that she did not want that moment who agreed to continue to
support a birther runs his grandson in the consulate mansion in Hamburg for as
long as possible when he was very young,
Hahn's believed that black people were the superior race.
His family was wealthy and most of the German people,
they were poor by comparison.
They also had several maids and servants that were all white.
On top of that,
Beth is friends which fuss over him as a toddler.
His compliment his skin whenever he went by Han's never met his father and Pesan
only communicated with him through letters because of this.
His grandfather stepped in to help raise him and he grew up having a very happy
childhood when he was seven years old,
king [inaudible] who was asked by the president of Liberia to return to his home
country and his duty as the gem and consulates when it was [inaudible].
He offered to bring a Hamza and birth that's he live with him in Liberia,
but she refused to leave when she knew that I'll hodge didn't want to marry her,
but she was an independent woman and she decided to go back to work as a nurse
and raise.
Hans is a single mum.
They moved into a working class neighborhood in bomb bag where they could only
afford to rent an attic.
Apartment.
Han's became friends with two boys in the neighborhood named at feet and Klaus.
They played together every day.
The three boys,
they were good kids and they got to know many of the people that in their town,
even though he was able to make close friends,
homes was bullied by the other boys in school for the color of his skin.
Children would towards in with a racist.
Ryan that is so offensive,
we're just not going to repeat it.
In this video,
the children said that his skin was dirty and they said horrible things about
his mother.
Despite all of this bullying,
Hans was incredibly bright and it was one of the smartest kids in the class.
He wants it to be an engineer.
When he grew up and he drew sketches of bridges from a very young age,
his teacher encouraged him to pursue this career even though she secretly
thought that it would not be possible in Nazi occupied Germany when he was seven
years old.
Hamza is babysitters,
so a swastika badge on his sweater so that he could wear it to school.
He wants it to prove to all of his bullies that he wants a German.
Of course it was a child and he didn't fully understands what the Nazi met.
A photographer at the school have snapped a picture of him wearing the swastika.
When Allianz,
his mothers or him wearing his,
when he got home,
she quickly removed the symbol telling him that their family did not believe in
the Nazi party.
However,
like a lot of other kids rebelled against his mother and continued to try to fit
in with the rest of the children in the school.
In 1935 when Hans was nine years old,
the Nuremberg laws were passed in Germany,
which made it illegal for Ariens and non Ariens to have sex or get married.
There's included anyone who is not born with pure German blood,
which included Jews remo and of course black people.
Han's Masa Quad was classified as a non Arian.
His mother sheltered him from learning about the Nuremberg laws.
She wanted him to have as normal a childhood as possible.
He could not understand why so many people were being mean to him and see once
to know why he couldn't just be like everyone else.
People would point stare at him in the street and whisper about the color of his
skin.
Back in the 1930s the slang term that everyone uses for black people in Germany
was the n word,
so you can imagine what that was like,
why people were calling him this all day,
every day.
He desperately wanted to fit in and was willing to go along with what everyone
else was doing.
When Holmes was in school,
he sat in the classroom together with the other German children.
He was taught about how Hitler was a hero,
save the nation from poverty and town.
Germany was the greatest country in the world.
The minds of these young children,
and they were obviously being brainwashed,
but none of these kids knew that the Nazis were killing and torturing innocent
people and they grew up to be not all followers of off Hitler.
When the boys 10 10 years old,
it became mandatory for them to join the Hitler youth.
From Honda's perspective,
the members of the Hitler youth walk cool uniforms and it just seems like
joining a club like the boy scouts,
Hitler youth got to take days off school and they marched in parades while
crowds cheered and fireworks were set off in their honor.
Propaganda posters,
they were everywhere and it made it seem like the Hitler youth were able to play
games all day and receive a lot of special treatments.
There was even a novel titled Headley Youth Cracks that came out in 1932 it's
the movie version premiered in 1933 comic books and Disney movies.
They were banned in Germany,
so these kids looked up to these Nazi characters of propaganda as their heroes
instead of the American versions in 1936 hands turn 10 years old and he believed
that it was finally time for him to join the Nazi party.
All of the boys in Hamza schools stood in the yard and the principal called out
their names one by one to announce their official enlistment in the Hitler
youth.
Han's stood and he waited in anticipation of his name to be called,
but it never was.
Out of 800 kids,
he was the last one left standing for anyone who was felt the pain of being
picked last in gym class as a kid.
Imagine the humiliation of that,
but times a thousand determines to be included.
Harms went with his best friends.
Do you hit the youth office in Hamburg to try and sign up,
but they did not allow him to join either because he was not an area in the
assays even began to hang signs in his local playgrounds saying that a non Arion
children were no longer allowed to play,
that his friend's parents appreciated how badly Hans wanted to join the Nazi
party,
which kept him in good graces with most of the adults in his life,
but it was still difficult.
The one ends only thing that could help restore some of Han's.
His pride in his heritage that year was the fact that there's an African
American runner named Jesse Owens dominated the Berlin Olympics in 1936 this
caused a huge scandal for the Nazis who were trying to prove to the worlds that
they're Aryan.
Race was the best at everything
growing up.
Hans would have no way of knowing that despite all of the horrible things he
went through.
He was actually extremely lucky.
There were very few Afro Germans living in the country during the war,
since Germany had colonized parts of Africa or exterminating them from their
main lands was a low priority compared to the Jews and Romer.
However,
a German anthropologist called Dr. Wolf Gang are,
they released a study that concluded that mixed race children were genetically
inferior to pure areas.
He said that they weren't aggressive and dangerous.
The mothers were basically just incubators for an alien race that wasn't fully
human.
He believes that it was necessary to sterilize all mixed race people who were
left living in Germany,
many Afro and Asian German people.
They were caught by the SS and they were forced to undergo surgeries that would
sterilize them so that they could no longer have children and pass on that DNA.
Hans [inaudible] was able to avoid this face because the authorities knew that
he was a prince and he was protected zones.
Uh,
a sort of diplomatic immunity when he became a teenager Parnes found out is that
even though he was a full Jen and citizen,
the Nazi laws prevented him from having any hope of a successful future.
Since he was non Arion poems was not allowed to pursue higher education,
so his dreams of an engineering degree and designing bridges,
they were crushed.
He tried to enlist in the German army after graduating high school,
but he was denied entry because of his race non Aryans.
They were not allowed to hold a job and they were not allowed to earn an income
either.
The Nazi government made sure that he was left with almost no hope of having any
kind of life after high school.
Thankfully our local blacksmith took him under his wing as an apprentice.
After learning his craft,
he went to a job counselor to see if he could get a work assignment.
He did not expect much to happen since he knew that he was not allowed to work,
but he showed up with examples of the things that he had created during his
apprenticeship.
He hopes that maybe they would see as skill and make an exception to the rules.
The SSL looked over his papers and told him that he could not give him a job,
but someday soon he believed that headline would help Germany retake that
colonies in Africa and they would need loyal black men like him to help them.
Homes began dating a white girl for a short period of time and he took a dancing
at my clubs that played American swing music,
which had been banned by the Nazi governments.
He was taking a lot of risks,
especially since this girl's father was an ss officer.
They have to meet in secret at night.
One evening he was caught and brought into the police station.
Dating a white girl was violating the Nuremberg laws and to make matters worse,
the police officer's that picked him up,
claimed that he was trying to muck up,
so I'm sure relationships,
they were forbidden and they were classified as race to fireman's by the race
loss.
This would have been a serious enough crimes up,
send them to a concentration camp.
Thankfully,
one of the police officers from his neighborhood recognized him and vouched for
his good character.
He was able to get off the hook,
but he had to end the relationship because it was far too dangerous for them to
be together.
During the war,
the Germans kept African prisoners of war separate from white people.
They were sent to a prison called les [inaudible] blogs where they were tortured
and treated like animals.
The fact that harms Massaquoi was denied entry to the German army was a real
blessing in disguise because he would never have to carry the weight of guilt on
his shoulders for participating in crimes against humanity.
On behalf of the Nazis.
Many of his close friends that he grew up with,
they would end up dying in the war when the allies were bombing Germany hands
and his mother pat to live in hiding.
During the period following the allies near destruction of Hamburg,
he befriended the family of Ralph Giordano,
a half Jewish acquaintance of these swing kids,
jazz,
ots.
The GL.
Donna is managed to survive the war by hiding and help it to mass acquire and
his mother secure and nearby basement after their handbag neighborhood was
destroyed.
Geodon.
No.
A lifelong friends became a renowned journalist as well in 1945 when the war was
over.
Neither of them has anything left.
Horns,
nuances play the saxophone,
so he got a job playing jazz and swing and nightclubs for the American soldiers,
which supported him and his mother until they could move on with their lives.
When World War One was over,
American troops swept stationed in Germany and black men entered this all white
country.
Once again,
just like the era of the Rhineland bastards,
more mixed race babies were born when German women had relationships with black
soldiers since they were fresh out of the Nazi regime.
Racism was still a very powerful force in Germany.
The vast majority of these mothers,
they did not want to keep that babies and thousands of mixed race children given
to orphanages.
Ebony magazine brought attention to the issue by coming out with a now famous
cover with an image of a black child with bright blue eyes saying this home's
needed for 10 thousands Brown orphans,
thousands of American families steps help to adopt these children and bring them
over to the United States.
But many of them remains to start a new generation of Afro German people in 1948
harms master across Faba.
They'll hodge was able to arrange for him to leave Germany and moved to Liberia
so that they could meet each other face to face for the first time.
Hamza realize that while his mother had always trying to speak one of them,
his father was actually rather arrogant and selfish,
so I think did not have a very good relationship.
Even though we thought the Liberia was a beautiful country and he could have
inherited a crown,
Hans did not want to stay there for the rest of his life.
He emigrated to the United States with a student visa because he plans on going
to college.
Unfortunately,
there was a fairly substantial mix up in the paperwork and he was forced to
serve in the Korean War for two years as a paratrooper,
even though he was not even an American citizen in 1950 he was finally able to
start his college classes at 24 years old and a journalism degree from the
University of Illinois.
After graduating,
he works for an African American publication called jet magazine and Lisa moved
to Chicago to work as the editor of Ebony magazine,
how's got married and started a family of his own in the United States for
years.
He only told the story of his life in Nazi Germany to his children and only
decided to write his autobiography destined to witness.
Growing up back in Nazi Germany after he retired from his journalism career in
1999 the story of his life was shocking to a lot of people and was eventually
made into a German movie in 2006 all's well that ends well.
Helen's mass acquire rose and quite as satisfied with the way my life has turned
out to be.
I survived to tell the piece of history I was a witness off.
At the same time,
I wish everyone could have a happy childhood within a fast society and that's
definitely not my case.
Has Master Quad died in 2013 on his birthday after turning 87 years old at the
time of his death mask.
While I was married to the love of his life,
Catherine resave MassEquality,
he had two songs by a previous Steve and Holmes Jr,
who also survived him.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe and as always,
thank you for watching.